kingdom tower will be the tallest
building in the world in about four
years it is part of a massive master
plan it's fun to design new buildings
and especially if they're large and
interesting really behind all of that we
hope is a kind of seriousness about the
problems that we encounter so I think
for those people who have those skill
sets that can take on these subject
matters we take on the buildings you
take on the cities we're lucky to have a
lot of exposure a lot of different
things because we have a lot of projects
around the world so there's almost
nothing that you see that you don't feel
couldn't be improved and I think we look
for designed to help us solve almost
everything we do if you look closely at
this tower you will see that it's
conceived of three legs like a tripod
and the wind behavior of super tall as
you might know is very specific what we
discovered was that we could actually
concentrate heat from this building
basically onto itself and generate power
from the shape of the building so it is
its own power plant to a degree I think
extra-large projects have a lot of
impacts that you can actually trace over
time and so for us it's much more
important to have extra-large ideas